[Applause]
you are stop it
stop it you're making me blush all over
could be the hives so happy Thursday
everyone I love Thursdays because
they're like Tuesdays hotter mysterious
cousin whereas Tuesday says sorry guys I
have to stay in and do my homework
Thursday is like hey what are you doing
later
why don't you swing by my van and we can
party
I just had the upholstery Scotch guarded
speaking of parties what a transition
this week we saw an amazing contrast to
two Governors and their inauguration
speeches while one spoke of celebrating
policies that led to unprecedented
population growth the other groveled to
Citizens she once mocked for leaving her
state
first the Empress of eyebrows
vowing to make her State a better place
to live
well as soon as she figures out who
replaced her Botox with Crazy Glue
rolling
we must and will
make our state safer
means New Yorkers can walk our streets
ride our Subways our kids can go to
school free from fear we have to make
our state more affordable New Yorkers
are just struggling to pay rent food and
gas to get to their jobs they're hurting
and we must reverse the trend of people
leaving our state in search of lower
costs and opportunities elsewhere yeah
so she's ordered the National Guard to
bomb Florida in Texas she has no other
Solutions but she now admits people are
leaving in search of lower costs and
opportunities elsewhere I guess that
includes the opportunity to not get
stabbed or pushed in front of a Subway
activities that blossomed under her
watch as she continues to defend no cash
bail of course this is the same jackass
who just a few months ago told unhappy
New Yorkers to beat it to Florida turns
out she was giving them good advice and
we're here to say
that the era of trump and zeldin and
Molinaro just jump on a bus and head
down to Florida where you belong okay
get out of town get out of town yeah
notice how she said bus
even she knows that thanks to her higher
taxes and gas prices we can't afford to
fly or drive
so the message was clear take a hike if
you disagree with My Views and if you're
headed to The Villages bring a lot of
condoms
believe me I've been there foreign
but now that this Hypocrites in office
she's begging all those taxpayers that
she once mocked to come back she's like
a blubbering ex pleading for forgiveness
after dumping you and then seeing you
suddenly date a richer healthier partner
I'd say she's two-faced which is good
since the one she already has is
stretched too thin
and as usual the media is letting this
slide check out this headline from The
New York Times quote at inauguration
local vows to make New York safer and
more affordable
wait you mean like Florida
or Texas or at this rate Somalia
what is stupid headline that's like
saying after killing his wife OJ hopes
to let his next wife live
thank you
yeah he was acquitted by his peers
you're right you're right
but where did damsai coco think this was
headed did they think people would be
forever okay with living in this liberal
hell hole oh but no New York has such
great theater that's true but it's hard
to take your sister to see Revival of
Miss Saigon starring Jim Belushi if
she's recovering from a stabbing in
Times Square
fact is policies like punishing tax
rates Rising crime and overbearing
coveted restrictions created a place so
bad that the only way to keep residents
from leaving is if there's a Berlin wall
around them and now they act like they
don't see this coming sorry hokel you
can't say your eyes weren't wide open
[Laughter]
I'm not letting this go it's obvious I
miss stelter
because it's not the guy begging for
change in Times Square who left town
it's the people who used to toss the guy
a buck who left it's the rich who pay
the taxes who keep cities afloat and
it's not just them who left corporations
bolted like James Corden fleeing a
restaurant when the bill comes
hell in hindsight AOC did Jeff Bezos a
favor by keeping him out of this
hellscape Barclays Morgan Stanley
Goldman Sachs have relocated jobs to
Florida North Carolina Tennessee where
people are polite and heavily armed the
way God intended
at least they didn't shoot their guns in
the air
anyway tech companies did the same in
Liberal run California with jobs fleeing
to Texas to me it's a good sign it's
capitalism having an allergic reaction
to socialism and while Hoka was begging
people to come back Governor Ron
DeSantis was congratulating them on
getting out
the policies pursued by these states
have sparked a mass Exodus of productive
Americans from these jurisdictions with
Florida serving as the most desired
destination a Promised Land of Sanity
many of these cities and states have
embraced faddish ideology at the expense
of enduring principle we will not allow
reality facts and Truth to become
optional we will never surrender to the
woke mob Florida is where woke goes to
die
yeah so
where woke goes to die that should be
the new state motto because it's true it
is where the woke go to die well that
and the elderly
and I don't I don't blame them it's
great
I'm gonna go there and die soon New
Hampshire's been saying live for free or
die for 75 years and when's the last
time they killed anybody
phonies but DeSantis is Right both
California and New York had six-figure
population loss since 2020. while Texas
and Florida have seen growth in the
six-figure range bottom line the blue
states have their work cut out for them
otherwise in five years when someone
farts in La New York or SF it's gonna
Echo for miles
but hey they may already be on the case
check out this ad I saw late last night
hey all you great people who left New
York for Florida we want you
they've made tons of changes since
you've been gone and you're gonna love
what we've done with the place
like in our libraries where every night
is now dudes who dress like ladies night
and we heard you hate unnecessary
lockdowns
which is why we're not locking down
anyone including the Central Park
masturbator the downtown defecator and
The Riddler plus Why Pay 250 bucks to
see Mickey Mouse when you can see tons
of real mice for free wow that's awesome
that's right kid and we've got tons of
entertainment options for the whole
family like crazy guy yelling on street
corner and sidewalk slasher and if you
felt like there's too many old people in
Florida don't worry in New York our
leaders took care of that years ago and
in Florida it's hot all the time but New
York has all four seasons hot really hot
cold yes so come back to New York where
we promise to kill you less
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
he makes wing tips in stripes and sock
garters look sexy host of Kudlow on Fox
Business Larry goodler
his wits are drier than a martini
stirred with beef jerky best-selling
author and Fox News contributor Douglas
Murray
she's banned for more restaurants than
trans fats Fox News contributor captive
foreign
lifts free weights because gyms are
afraid to charge him my massive sidewick
in the nwa's World Heavyweight Champion
pirate
Lawrence it's always a pleasure to see
you uh what do you make of hokel's
flip-flop does she assume that we will
just forgot about this what did she flip
flop from well remember she told
everybody to leave and now she wants a
month oh now she wants him back well
she's going to lose him anyway she is a
loser
uh you're right about you're right about
the botox problem in the eyebrows that
was Pelosi remember Pelosi's eyes never
blinked for four or five years yeah I'm
gonna do the same thing though because
you know what blinking takes a lot of
work
so if I can freeze my face and never
have to Blink think about how I could
use that energy and other more proactive
ways
as I was saying uh before you started
that
yeah I think the best part of the story
by the by is that Rhonda Stanis gave a
heck of a good second inaugural speech
and you know you're looking at a very
serious presidential candidate and the
the woke stuff is important very
important but also important he you know
doesn't want to spend a lot of money he
will not tolerate higher taxes he's not
anti-business regulator he's not
anti-fossil fuels I mean everything New
York isn't Florida is yeah and the other
thing about hokel is and I think you
forgot this in your monologue there is
no electricity in New York anymore
really you can't get electricity it's
either too expensive or no pipelines or
no natural gas or no nuclear power so it
could be a very chilly winter which will
play in Tehran DeSantis hands and
DeSantis should run against a hokel he
should run against the Gavin Newsom of
California that would be a great choice
I think that's it's a model New York
bottle as you say or a California model
for California you got that right versus
a free market capitalist model there you
can guess who's winning yeah well we
know because I said so already
geez Larry why do you have to just keep
we have to talk after this really yes
about Botox yes Douglas
you moved from England to New York would
you ever consider moving from New York
to say Florida
I was actually in Florida the other day
and friends there who've moved from New
York I mean the fact you turn up with
catalogs for properties now yeah it's
quite annoying they're very Evangelical
they're like you've got to move down
here why didn't you move down here the
taxes are better the weather's better
and everything I say I didn't leave
London to move to a suburb of Miami yeah
you know you like the city I love the
city yeah I love New York I think it's a
great have you ever been to Jacksonville
yes great restaurants people Cheesecake
Factory as far as you can see I know
look I don't and I don't want to be down
on Miami I don't be down on any of these
places Austin Nashville all these other
places but New York is New York it's one
of the greatest cities of the world it's
going it's down and it's like a bit of
them yeah I'm back you're not here for
the theater I'm I'm here for you Greg as
I am here finally he admits it no uh but
uh it's a pretty great to Larry's Point
it's a great comparison right now what
we're seeing yeah it is it is and I mean
it is absurd I mean it is as you said in
your monologue it's like sort of it's a
sort of teenage like thing I love you I
hate you I love you
um go away leave uh come back why aren't
you coming back
She chased away I mean you know we what
this city lost what was it 10 of higher
earners just in 2020. rich people the
rich people the people paying the burden
of the taxes yes uh you support the
homeless who support the homeless all of
this stuff and now everyone's worrying
about the deficit and much what you
there are no rich people in New York
they're gone yeah they're completely
gone which is a tragedy you need rich
people yeah someone has to stand up for
rich people Greg I will be that person I
want to be the Gandhi for the rich yeah
thank you
it's just an excuse to wear a diaper
it's not sure what did he I don't know
what that means wear a diaper I don't
know what I'm talking about haven't we
made that clear since this show started
I have no expertise in anything Kat I
bet you have some sort of relationship
allegory to what Kathy hokel was talking
about or did I already use it yeah
because yours doesn't work because the
relationships that are like go away
never want to see you again and please
come back oh there's always like this
insane sexual chemistry yes which I
don't feel for Kathy
I don't think she has it for me either
so it's fair yeah yeah uh but she has
this eye you know she wants to make New
York more affordable but so I have a
really good idea for her but it might be
a little crazy
um when people make money let them keep
it
right I
crime problem gets too much credit for
sending people away when really even if
new in New York there was a zero percent
chance you'd get mugged on the street
there's still the 100 chance that you're
gonna get mugged by the state yeah which
in Florida there's not so that's the
biggest thing for me it's so true it's
so true I don't think people understand
how high I think it's the highest in the
country or maybe California it is insane
Tyra's last word to you what say you
about my tremendous monologue I saw you
almost cry yes I almost cry every day
before I come on
what I think is funny is when her turns
up
she moves to Florida I think that that's
definitely going to happen and
you two think you're fooling people by
saying all the rich people left they
have it they're right over here
cut a little trying to be I was like
yeah I didn't know you moved yeah he's
trying to lay low like you know hey
don't pay anything question to me guys a
guy's got to earn a living time you're
so rich your accountant has an
accountant
this is Gilded Age stuff someone's got
to stand up for rich people that's all
I'm saying I mean there's a library risk
being here you're like the last one the
rich ghost of New York
I just think like she doesn't can't make
up her mind and not to disagree with you
but it's not teenage it's not a teenage
girl that's a grown-ass woman you've
been in a relationship for a long time
with who will tell you to get the hell
out of the house and as you walk outside
where you think you going yeah
I'm like what you said get out
Now you listen
get back in the house what are the
neighbors gonna say so that's the same
thing with New York they're mad the the
people left but then they have to
pretend like good riddance yeah because
then the rest of us get to deal with it
and again I love the fact that you love
New York
give it another six months we're gonna
bring it back to everyone ask him the
question and when he has half the
Phantom of the Opera mask on from the
stabbing
we'll see how he's doing
all right I'll go into musical theater
I just gotta earn a little bit you have
like 17 living
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else